hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay what are we
doing oh we're going in here why not I
didn't I just give a get everything in
the medical area when I got here oh wait
a minute no I've gone gone this way huh
huh huh huh that big guy the big guy
coming the big guy
don't whisper at me what the heck the
door closed oh come on
eight survivors reports of a massive
creature entered the hydroponic spectrum
outside the ship Leviathan okay that
makes sense I came out of here I don't
even know where I'm going anymore okay
you're here why not why not go further
into the place that's terrifying me why
do I have to do all this oh wait no I'm
going back to where oh okay I didn't I
just get it when I got here oh wait I
got another chemical and
[Applause]
okay buddy
both walks that's a great sign head back
to the tram station and get up to
hydroponics as fast as you can
still no response from Hammond so
there's no telling how contaminated that
Beckett oh it's very big very what has
my air spirit misplaced as it may be I
think I think you should see the whole
plant who you should not spoil the hive
minds are friends you deserve to witness
that I place a hive mind always good
okay thank you thank you for opening
opening the door
this guy's gonna show me something
apparently I'm sure what but I'm sure
it's good okay all right let's tap that
save station where I'm not here that
sounds good to me
and lots of lockers gimme oh yeah
bullets credits more bullets even more
bullets oh oh
their divine glory across them oh oh no
you won't I will leave you know
yeah that's not gonna happen
I'll bring it on I got a stasis recharge
thing so you're you're blowing bro
you're just blowing hey who's there
I hear something oh yeah often does a
sing recharge what
Oh
stay down
all right what am I doing here oh what's
up here I'm stupid oh I get it okay I'm
smart I get it I got it I got it I can
dig it I hey hey buddy that's why
there's a sneeze hey buddy come on you
stay stay there when I go I think freeze
you I think you like the other guys yeah
whoa I saw tentacles move
bah bah yeah that thing you didn't even
see it
I've managed to override Mercer's
lockdown there's a secondary tram
station nearby and you can take it to
hydroponics let's just hope there's
enough time there's always enough time
but I'm on the job I get things done
no stop a box more bullets for me
300 bullets will never need to restock
the new target power node crouches shoot
a button again
I want to push it damn you this way well
what was that whatever I thought I heard
an item
this looks good whoa I back at the tram
how did I get back here I didn't wait
that door led right to here how
wait I had to have missed something wow
that is dark I had to miss something
right there's no way that the cryogenics
lab went right back to the tram I had to
come in somewhere maybe I'm just losing
my mind or maybe there's just a
different area I don't
whoa don't be messing with me
back on nothing in here okay we're good
we're good
I think we got another chapter done
Berto yeah goodbye lethal devotion I do
not like that big monster I wasn't that
big but it was big ish going going yep
yep yeah
boy environmental hazard select your
weapons on the inventory screen to
assign them to different quick slots I
only need one weapon mm-hmm all right
hydroponics hydroponics is the the
growing of vegetables on a water bed
instead of its soil it's very useful and
very quick for they they do it a lot
with cabbage and stuff like that plants
like that that are high in water I'm
pleased to say that we're working close
to maximum capacity at the present time
are you now all flora is healthy and
thriving and food yield has created a
surplus yeah that's not the case now I
was going to pass the surplus on to the
colony but the captain has given a
no-fly order that's smart no my
opposition to that order everyone knows
they're in trouble down there and I
don't see what denying them our surplus
will achieve don't like bodies
oh it's a bathroom Oh what happened in
this bathroom Oh Oh weird their heads go
touching that toilet is a bad bathroom
why are you moving I thought that they
moved
han shot first someone did not blush oh
so many bodies don't get up just bodies
don't get up don't get up oh people
don't know how to what what what ah all
right didn't scare me
what's that what was that
contact energy Oh energy for the ammo
for the contact okay
I hate bathrooms bathrooms and [ __ ]
games are the worst go in the right way
um okay I elevator
let's see here
hmm
Oh what was that I heard that I heard
something you guys heard something I
heard something
oh look at that fresh vegetables contact
in it yeah oh hey buddy how you wait
y'all right there some so you get
infected don't make me kill you hey what
what hi hi hi back off yeah oh yeah
itself a food storage heart sounds good
crew that was on this deck
I think there was poisoning the air
those bastards
they've been transformed I saw one of
them bloated swollen the poison
factories yeah we need to take him out
we can still breathe you need to get to
cleaner air you're not going to be able
to help Isaac in your condition
Isaac I'm scanning the area now he's
right there's something really big in
food storage but I can't get a good scan
monitor readings are off the scale be
careful
will do thanks for telling me to be
careful I wasn't gonna hi buddy you're
gonna get out of here you're gonna you
don't look so good need a hand if I
could help you up with my gun nope Wow
taking on the big baddies gonna have to
wait till next episode because I gotta
cut it here thank you guys so much for
watching as always I appreciate every
single one of you and I will see you in
the next part bye bye